so now you're a point guard every one of
these guys just came out of high school
their stats in high school they're the
best player oh no collars you're the
best player then you're coming on a team
they're number five right delete them I
had to get them to buy into that you may
be the fifth option but that's an
important role that you're playing so
you made every position be important
that's right every person is important
no matter what your role is it's an
important role and if you don't do your
job
we can't win was it a one-on-one
conversation with it a group
oh yeah no it's both were you're more
one-on-one over first one on woke up you
have to do it got on one first and you
have to uplift the guy you have to make
them feel like they're important and and
so I would say to James hey man you was
a man at North Carolina no question
about it but when I come down on this
break I'm looking for Kareem first you
told them that oh yeah and you have to
be happy with that and then if I got
that Lane and I'm shaking and bacon and
I see that seam and I can get to through
through that seam to the basket then I'm
gonna take the shot but if I can't take
it and Kareem not over guess what baby
you gonna get it you got a lot of so you
have to help them understand and then
everybody gets comfortable with that and
the main goal was for us to win
you